Gretchen Dutschke auf den
Spuren der Revolte:
Bei jeder Demo war sie damals mit dabei,
die Austauschstudentin aus den USA,
die sich in den Studentenführer
Rudi Dutschke verguckte –
und er sich in sie, Hochzeit inklusive.
Seine Stimme war die Stimme des Protests.
Revolution ist ein langer, komplizierter
Prozess, wo der Mensch anders werden muss!
Nichts weniger als sich und die Welt
verändern wollten sie damals.
Anders leben, anders lieben – frei,
friedlich, solidarisch.
Vor der Technischen Universität in
Berlin trifft Gretchen Dutschke
auf die Studentenproteste von heute.
Mehr Lohn für Miete und Champagner!
Okay …
Die Zeiten haben sich geändert: Um Geld
geht es – nicht so sehr um Politik.
Wie ist es gelungen, damals 20.000 Leute
auf die Straße zu kriegen?
Weil das kriegen wir nicht hin.
Das aber war am Anfang auch nicht.
Es gab natürlich andere Faktoren:
Also, Vietnamkrieg hat eine sehr
große Rolle gespielt.
Es waren die großen Themen, für die
sie vor 50 Jahren kämpften.
Die 68er-Bewegung hat Politik sehr populär
gemacht, also, dass sich viele auch
damit beschäftigen wollen,
und das ist wieder abgeflaut …
also, dass die Leute irgendwie meinen,
Politik bringt nichts.
Man hat absolut gedacht, dass man auf
der richtigen Seite der Geschichte steht.
Und dass das wirklich was erreichen wird
– dass wir werden was erreichen.
Auch Wolfgang Wieland wollte etwas
erreichen. Als Jura-Student
im ersten Semester geht er 1967 zur
Demonstration vor der Deutschen Oper.
Der Schah von Persien ist zu Besuch.
Die Studenten protestieren gegen
sein Unrechtsregime – die Berliner Polizei
schlägt auf sie ein,
erschießt sogar einen von ihnen:
Benno Ohnesorg.
Jeder hatte das Gefühl: Benno Ohnesorg,
das hättest du selber auch sein können.
Sie haben uns hier grundlos
zusammengeprügelt. Das waren ja
nicht nur die Schüsse, … eine Art Gemetzel,
das hier stattfand.
Auch die Presse macht mobil gegen
die Demonstranten, insbesondere
die „Bild“-Zeitung des Verlegers
Axel Springer.
Zehn Monate später fallen wieder Schüsse:
Ein verwirrter Hilfsarbeiter
will Studentenführer Rudi Dutschke töten.
Der überlebt schwer verletzt.
Wenn die „Bild“-Zeitung dann die Leute
aufgehetzt haben [hat],
haben die Leute das einfach geglaubt –
und ließen sich aufhetzen!
Vor dem Axel-Springer-Haus eskaliert
der Protest.
Rudi Dutschke! Rudi Dutschke! …
Die Regierung verabschiedet die so
genannten Notstandsgesetze,
kann ab jetzt die Grundrechte einschränken
– gut zwanzig Jahre nach der Nazi-Diktatur
ein Schock für die Studenten.
Das war die Angst, dass die
kurze Phase der Demokratie
in der Alt-Bundesrepublik schon
wieder vorbei ist.
Doch es kommt anders: 1969,
der Amtsantritt von Willy Brandt
– zum ersten Mal ist ein
Sozialdemokrat Bundeskanzler.
Und die 68er verändern nicht die Welt,
aber den Alltag:
Kindererziehung, Arbeit, Liebe
– alles wird offener, liberaler.
Eine Kulturrevolution:
sanft, aber nachhaltig.
Das war hinterher ein anderer
Staat als vorher.
Gretchen Dutschkes Mann Rudi stirbt 1979
an den Spätfolgen des Attentats.
Heute lebt sie in einem
feministischen Wohnprojekt.
Und sie ist Mitglied bei den Grünen,
kämpft dort für eine bessere Welt.
Ich denke bis heute, dass
diese[s] Umweltproblem vielleicht das
dringendste ist, erst mal. Weil wenn wir
keine Welt haben, dann haben wir gar nix.
Wolfgang Wieland hat den Marsch durch
die Institutionen angetreten.
Ende der 70er hat er die Berliner Grünen
mitgegründet und war später sogar
Justizsenator – mit Dienstwagen
und Krawatte.
Demonstrieren geht er immer noch:
gegen rechts. Denn auch hierzulande
sind die Rechtspopulisten auf
dem Vormarsch.
Die „Alternative für Deutschland“, AfD,
kam bei der letzten Bundestagswahl
auf zwölf Prozent der Stimmen.
Die AfD protestiert in dem Sinn gegen
die Schwächsten der Gesellschaft.
Und sie macht das mit populistischen
Themen, mit Rassismus, mit Ausgrenzung,
mit Treten nach unten. Unser Protest ist
immer gegen oben gerichtet gewesen.
Die sind zwölf Prozent – wir sind ...
wir sind was? 88 Prozent oder was, nicht?
Also, die können es uns
nicht wegnehmen.
Direkt vor dem Axel-Springer-Haus,
dem Sitz der „Bild“-Zeitung,
ist inzwischen eine Straße nach
Rudi Dutschke benannt.
Die 68er sind offensichtlich angekommen:
in einem Land, das sie einst bekämpften,
dann veränderten – und nun gegen rechts
verteidigen. Der Kampf geht weiter.